Zoroastrianism is a religion that not
many people know too much about or have
indeed ever heard of to sum the extent
of that knowledge is that it's the
religion that Freddie Mercury belonged
to but the fact is or Astron ism
historically speaking is one of the most
important religions to have ever existed
[Applause]
the religion of Zoroastrianism is old
it's very old it originates in what is
today Iran in the region known as Persia
with the appearance of the prophets and
quote-unquote founder Zarathustra also
known as Zoroaster in Greek now asked
with similar ancient figures like him
it's very very hard basically impossible
to pin down an exact date for when he
lived but scholars suggest that he might
have lived around
well between 1400 to 1200 BCE while
others also say that it may have lived
around 800 BCE so there isn't consensus
about this the religion practiced in
Persia prior to zarathustra's mission
was a kind of polytheism or paganism
very closely connected to the Vedic
tradition in India from which other
religions like Hinduism and Jainism and
Buddhism also later developed this can
be seen by the fact that many of the
gods cross over between the two
traditions but have slightly different
names based on the language this
includes gods like Saraswathi and Indra
and and many others
the deities worshipped by the Persians
were associated with things like water
and fire as well as natural phenomena or
abstract concepts like love for wisdom
the cult and worships running these
deities included things like offerings
and animal sacrifice all performed by a
class of priests very similar to the
Brahmins of the Indian context the
prophet and founder Zarathustra most
likely belonged to this class of priests
it is said that he would wander around
Persia looking for wisdom and truth and
during these travels he would see a lot
of injustice a lot of violence and just
a lot of nasty stuff in general
which would of course influence the very
ethically based message that he would
later convey and his life according to
tradition is said to have changed
dramatically one day when he was
celebrating a spring festival and during
this festival he went down to the water
to fetch or fetch some water for the
festival
and after he had been standing in waist
high water and returned to shore being
thus ritually purified he then suddenly
had an intense vision of light and in
this light he experienced the presence
of the god Ahura Mazda and six other
radiant beings from which he then
received his first revelation the god
Ahura Mazda was nothing new to
Zarathustra or the Persians he was a God
who had been worshipped prior to this
and whose name literally means Lord
wisdom he was one of the more exalted
gods in the pantheon belonging to a
group of God's called the era's the
Indian equivalent of which is a Shura
but we're so unique about the revelation
that Zarathustra received and that he
would convey was that Ahura Mazda was no
longer just some God he was now the one
uncreated eternal God who was the
creator of the world and of everything
good hurah Mazda was the guardian and
embodiment of a concept called Asha
meaning the order of the universe and in
a moral sense also represented things
like righteousness and justice the
opposite of this is a term called drudge
synonymous with things like evil
falsehood and violence these forces were
not the creation of Ahura Mazda but by
another immortal being called Angra
Mainyu or the hostile spirit in the
teachings of Zarathustra the world of
creation is a constant battlefield
between the forces of Asha and drudge
between good and evil light and darkness
Zarathustra himself left behind a
collection of hymns known as the gothis
which was first orally transmitted and
then written down under the sasanian
empire the gatha's can be considered
these sort of most sacred scriptures to
the sir astron and are part of a larger
collection of sacred texts called the
avesta the rest of which was written
after Zoroaster or Zarathustra
and by priests a question that quickly
arises with this very strongly dualistic
outlook is the very nature of
Zoroastrianism theology some claim that
Sir Astron ism is a monotheistic
religion while others say that is a
dualistic faith or dualistic theology
scholars and zoroastrians alike have
never really been able to agree on
whether or not sir astron ism is a
monotheistic religion or not but if it
is that would be pretty significant
because then it would be most likely the
oldest monotheistic religion in the
world that we know of scholars like Mary
Boyce argues for the dualistic
alternative describing Ahura Mazda and
Angra Mainyu as equally uncreated
opposing forces while others like Farhan
Meir proposes a view where is our thirst
rest original message was that there was
but one God and dualistic forces were
part of his creation thus below him but
perhaps it's wiser to look at this from
a more nuanced perspective and not try
to define Zoroastrianism with such
arbitrary and anachronistic really terms
like monotheism or polytheism there have
been other arguments like that of James
Boyd and Donald Crosby who suggest that
none of the above explanations are good
enough
instead they propose that quote in brief
the interpretation we favor is that Sir
Astron ism combines cosmogonic dualism
and eschatological monotheism in a
matter unique to itself among the major
religions in the world this combination
results in a religious outlook which
cannot be categorized as either
straightforward dualism or
straightforward monotheism the fact is
that the old Iranian or Persian pantheon
of gods remain in the saw astron system
at least according to later
interpretations of its theological ideas
when the Prophet had his first vision at
the river it is said that he saw along
with the hood a master himself a group
of six lesser beings these are known as
the spenta mainyu or six lesser
divinities all representing different
attributes of the high god like
righteousness devotion and health while
remaining hierarchically beneath him and
sort of part of his creation there are
sometimes considered emanations of Ahura
Mazda were the symbolism of a torch
lighting other torch
used to describe this process of
emanation another term used to describe
these lesser divinities is ameesha spent
us or holy immortals but this term is
also used to refer to any lesser deity
who emanates from Ahura Mazda and
includes most of the old gods of the
Pantheon thus worship and veneration of
the old gods continued under
Zoroastrianism and especially of the
highest six divinities because these
represented attributes of the high god
hora Mazda and were thus worshiped
separately the exception to this is
another group of deities known as the
Davis which also has an Indian
equivalent of the same name these guards
represent things like violence and war
and thus they serve the hostile spirit
Angra Mainyu rather than a Mazda and
Zarathustra very strongly rejected any
worship of these Devas these deities in
Zoroastrian cosmology creation is seen
as cyclical and often divided into three
phases the first of which is called
simply creation it's the first phase
when how the Mazda God creates the world
in a perfect state free from all evil
and all darkness but as soon as this
creation comes about the evil spirit
Angra Mainyu attacks it and infiltrates
it with darkness and an evilness and
this starts the second phase known as
mixture when both good and evil light in
darkness exists alongside each other in
the world and are battling this is the
time we live in now
so obviously giant pandas are the
creation of Ahura Mazda while stepping
in water with your socks on is clearly
the creation of under menu human beings
are also important players in this
cosmic battle and much like the good
deities have a responsibility to promote
righteousness and goodness and expel
evil and darkness from the world this is
done in a number of ways but primarily
through the basic moral principle that
was laid down by Zarathustra which is
good thoughts good words and good deeds
thus humans and creation have a clear
purpose and so Astron ISM that is to
gradually expel the forces of Angra
Mainyu of evil until the third and final
phase is reached
it's called separation
creation is once again in a perfect
paradisal state given the fact that Sir
Arthur stressed message was so ethically
based he introduced certain ideas that
were revolutionary for his time for
example in his thought people would be
judged after death and this judgment
would lead either to reward or
punishment and most importantly departed
souls were judged based on their actions
in this life and not on things like
riches or status which was the case in
the earlier pagan religion thus reward
was open to anyone and so was
punishments we didn't matter if you were
rich what status you had if you've been
a bad person you would end up being
punished after death if you had been
deemed good and then you'll be able to
cross a bridge into a paradise of
delights but if you had been bad then
that bridge would contract to the size
of a blades edge and you would most
likely fall down into hell a place of
great torment and torture furthermore at
the end of time when the Battle of good
and evil is over all the bodies of the
Dead will be resurrected and subjected
to a Last Judgement Bonamassa after
which you will either live in hell or
remain in the paradise like land of the
perfected creation which is now free
from all evil and darkness in terms of
practice or Astron isms gone through a
number of developments throughout
history though astron been rather
negatively referred to as fire
worshippers by the Muslim conquerors for
example but this is a rather misleading
term it is true that fire plays an
important role in the practice and
symbolism of the faith serving as the
symbol for purity and God's wisdom and
light fire as well as water appeared to
have been a important part of ritual
fuzzer Astron since the very inception
but the appearance of things like fire
temples or heightened platforms with
fire altars appear to have been a much
later development probably sometime in
the again during the Achaemenid Empire
but nonetheless fires and temples did
become and still remain very important
aspects of the faith and their practice
connected to this fire and it's
representation of purity is the idea of
ritual purity which is one of the most
important as
Effects of this faith it is the duty of
every person to keep clean because you
know dirtiness or uncleanliness is an
aspect or manifestation of evil and
darkness this led to certain laws
regarding ritual purity which
unfortunately for example limited women
and their movements during their
menstrual periods for example because
they were seen as unclean for its
duration one can also see similar ideas
expressed in the rather famous funerary
rites of the Zoroastrians as the body
was considered unclean and once the soul
has departed from it the body was taken
out to an open space where it would be
eaten by animals and then the bones
would later be collected to await the
day of resurrection
why should keep in mind that this is all
connected to the cosmic battle between
Asha and Raj and thus seen as a
necessary and logical measure to fulfill
our purpose in creation moreover another
important ritual practice of
Zoroastrianism is the celebration of
seven yearly festivals all connected to
these six Amisha spent thus the higher
divinities and one also connected to
fire which could be seen as the sort of
lifeblood of all of them and the
festival of fire is known as no rules or
also known today as Persian New Year on
the day of the spring equinox and this
was meant originally to signify because
the summer is coming to signify the
partial and temporary victory of light
over darkness the priests of
Zoroastrianism is called Magi a term
that was used by the Greeks to refer to
the entire religion as well a fun fact
is that according to the New Testaments
there was three Magi that visited Jesus
in Bethlehem women carrying gifts also
known as sometimes as the three wise men
in fact this connection to other
religions is partly what makes or astron
isms so special if you remember what I
said in the beginning so astron ISM is
arguably one of the most important
religions in history and this is partly
due to how much it has affected the
religions of the world concepts
introduced by the Zoroastrians like
Heaven and Hell the Day of Resurrection
and the Last Judgment as well as the
dualistic cosmology with an evil
adversary through God and his servants
the Devas and even the idea of a coming
say
you're in Abrahamic terms in Messiah it
is highly probable that these ideas made
it into Judaism in the post exile period
and thus very much influenced its
development going forward these ideas
were then later picked up by both
Christianity and Islam and serves as
some of the most fundamental aspects of
these religions so it isn't entirely
wrong to say that many of the
fundamental principles of the three
Abrahamic world religions as well as the
Baha'i faith have their direct origins
in Zoroastrianism and the teachings of
Zarathustra after its initial spreads or
asterism really only became a
significant force on the world scene
with the appearance of the Achaemenid
Empire also known as the Persian Empire
which adopted the ration ISM as a kind
of state religion now this is the Empire
of course with Cyrus the Great and
barriers and Circe's and all these
people its doctrines further developed
over time and as it continued to serve
as the state religion for the other
empires to Silla kids and the sasanian
x' it sort of remains strong right up
into the time of the Arab invasion at
the advent of Islam after which it kind
of started to decline it is true that
the conquering Muslims often gave us or
Aston's I would say a hard time that for
much of history since then they have
been an oppressed minority but one
should also remember that in many
periods and by many people those
westerns but also considered among the
al-kitab the people of the book and thus
they were considered protected people by
the Muslims but this doesn't change the
fact that oppression still happened of
course temples were destroyed and so on
but one should be careful not to use a
reading of history that is too black or
whites in any of the two extreme
directions as a result of these
historical circumstances many of those
are Astraea new India and over time
they're developed two rather distinct
groups often referred to as on the one
hand the iranian Zoroastrians and on the
other the indian parsy's the latter of
which for demur curie belonged to a
discussion on the history and
distinction of these two groups will
have to be saved for another time but
this grouping still remains today but
nonetheless the persecution and
oppression that the Zoroastrians have
faced especially in Iran cannot be
ignored in a video
like this it still continues to this day
under the current Iranian leadership and
it's this unfortunate history has been a
contributing factor to the religions
decline in numbers the actual number of
Zoroastrians in the world today is
difficult to know for sure
partly due to the state of affairs in
Iran but a study conducted in 2012 by
the Federation of Zoroastrian
associations of North America shows that
the numbers might be slightly above
100,000 people which of course isn't a
lot and most of these live in India or
Central Iran with also diaspora
communities in places like North America
and Great Britain indeed Zoroastrianism
is sometimes called a dying religion due
to its decreasing numbers and partly due
to its reluctance to accept any converts
the reality might be such that in the
near future there won't be any
Zoroastrians left and this will be a
shame because it's a fascinating and
rich tradition and one that is
incredibly significant for our world
heritage and the development of the so
called world religions we probably
wouldn't be where we are without
Zoroastrianism and Zarathustra but let's
continue this discussion in the comments
for example do you think that
Zoroastrianism is a monotheistic or a
dualistic faith and do you think there's
any chance of it surviving into the
future to any zoroastrians out there I
hope I have represented your faith in a
fair and acceptable manner and I'll see
you next time
[Music]